well now some of our favorite reality TV  couples are all about mixing work and  play and not afraid of a little  competition our lauren zima saw that  firsthand when we teamed up with secrets  resorts and spas for a week of unlimited  luxury we figured you might know a thing  or two about competition what did you  guys learn about yourselves while  competing for love on TV I'm really bad  at sports I'm pretty easygoing would you  ever do a reality TV competition show  again not like a competition of the laws  he would know what sport I'm just gonna  let him do it all for the sake of your  relationships there won't be winners or  losers today alright Lauren who won guys  are they're really winners and losers  here yeah well you're all winners  because secrets has endless amenities  and entertainment day or night and we  have a great show planned for you  tonight  [Applause]  [Music]